il faut se rendre à la campagne dans
cette usine pour élaborer la recette du
bloc de béton de chanvre prenez trois
ingrédients de la chaîne vote le nom de
la tige de chambre concassées du Simon
naturel prompte extrait du massif de la
Chartreuse et un peu d'eau bien sûr le
procédé technique ne vous sera pas
entièrement dévoilé mais après sage et
quelques semaines de séchage on obtient
des blocs aux nombreuses vertus grâce à
la présence de chanvre qui va capter le
carbone via processus de photosynthèse à
la base on a un matériau bas carbone et
isolant mais en plus de ça le béton de
chance c'est un isolant avec de la masse
la masse ça apporte du confort l'été
déphasage inertie et la dernière
caractéristique qui va nous intéresser
dans le béton de chanvre c'est sa
capacité à réguler l'humidité environ 5
fois plus léger que du béton classique
les blocs de béton ne change sont
encastrables sans colle ni mortier à la
portée de tout Masson après de longues
recherches ce constructeur australien a
découvert ces blocs français et les
imports depuis 5 ans pour des chantiers
chez lui mais aussi en Nouvelle-Zélande
aux îles FID Ji aux États-Unis il a même
élaboré un matériau pour remplacer les
poteaux en béton armé
c'est très léger très très forte j'ai
fait quelques maisons en Australie de
système français qui marche bien ça il y
a pas de problème mais je voulais
avancer le système pour que ça soit
moins de problèmes moins de boutons et
plus vite à terme l'entrepreneur
aimerait construire des usines en
Australie et aux États-Unis pour
encourager une production agricole
locale de chanvre en France 20 000
hectares sont pour leur cultiver les
acteurs de la filière rêvent d'un coup
de pouce à cet instrument de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique c'est
une question qu'il faut adresser au
pouvoir public et ce qu'on est prêt à
subventionner le béton de champ aurait
pu largement les matériaux sourcés de
façon à décarboner l'acte de construire
ou de rénover tout simplement